the standard unit of information is the
bit which has a little bit of a funny
formula but it's really intuitive if we
just look at examples if you have an
observation that cuts your space of
possibilities in half we say that it has
one bit of information if instead a new
fact chops down that space of
possibilities by a factor of four we say
that it has two bits of information if
the observation cuts that space by a
factor of eight we say it's three bits
of information and so on and so forth so
now it's when you might want to take a
moment and pause and ask for yourself
what is the formula for information for
the number of bits in terms of the
probability of An
Occurrence well what we're saying here
is basically that when you take 1/2 to
the number of bits that's the same thing
as the probability which is the same
thing as saying two to the power of the
number of bits is one over the
probability which rearranges further to
saying the information is the log base 2
of 1 / the probability and sometimes you
see this with one more rearrangement
still where the information is the
negative log base 2 of the
probability